où nous nous tenons en ce moment, c'est
ce qu'on appelait smithsfield où john
smith a entraîné les troupes
en 167 et 8
et comme vous pouvez le voir, il est complètement
inondé et vous savez que c'est un
exemple parfait de l'élévation du niveau de la mer, du changement climatique
et de la façon dont il nous affecte
nous avons une fenêtre de cinq ans
à jamestown
pour commencer à atténuer sérieusement les
impacts du changement climatique ce que les
scientifiques et les autres planificateurs qui examinent
cela nous disent qu'après la
fermeture de cette fenêtre de cinq ans,
il devient
exponentiellement plus difficile d'atténuer
et de faire face aux impacts  du changement climatique
c'est l'une de mes solutions d'ingénierie préférées
pour le site et la préservation de
l'élévation du niveau de la mer le changement climatique est que
nous élevons les fondations
en pensant au public et à
sa capacité à voir cela à tout
moment,
nous avons créé ce sol  système et
maintenant nous avons un morceau de plastique, nous pouvons
deux personnes peuvent très rapidement
le mettre sur la pluie s'écoule et ensuite
nous pouvons continuer nos travaux
vous